عموما المشاهدين مساله تسليح اوكرانيا
بدبابات متطوره ليست سهله فالجزء الصعب هو
كيفيه نقل المركبات المدرعه الثقيله
والشاحنات القتاليه الاخرى الى الساحه
المعركه وهو ما اكده مسؤول امريكيون
لصحيفه نيوورك تايمز الذين قالوا ان الامر
قد يستغرق سنوات حتى تصل دبابات ابرامز
الى اي ساحه قتال اوكرانيه في الوقت نفسه
تدور مخاوف من استهداف في روسيا للطرق
والسكك الحديديه او لاماكن انطلاق المعدات
اثناء الشحنها الى الخطوط الاماميه في شرق
وجنوب اوكرانيا ما جعل الغرب يفكر بكيفيه
ارسال هذه الدبابات عبر قوافل خفيه عاده
ما تكون متخفيه في الظلام او مموهها
لحمايتها من اي هجوم اذا ايضا هناك
تساؤلات عديده مشاهدينا طرحت حول اهميه
هذه الدبابات في ساحه المعركه في حالي
وصولها اوكرانيا ترى ان الدبابات ضروريه
لاختراق الخطوط الروسيه ايضا للتغلب على
هجوم متوقع تحدثت عنه وسائل اعلاميه عده
خصوصا ان الدبابات ليوبارد اثنين صمم
تخصصا لتنافس الدبابات الروسيه تي 9 التي
يستخدمها الروس في حربهم ويعتقد الرئيس
الاوكراني بوليود ميرسي ان حوالي 300
دبابات ستساعد بلاده على هزيمه روسيا في
حين ان الاعلان الرسميه تحدث عن 16 دبابه
فقط
[موسيقى]